hello welcome to science vehicles from
science mission I am siddhesh of x and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of August
for let's start first we will discuss a
paper published by Bryan and colleagues
in nature communications on the role of
enterocytes glutenin transporter on the
development of metabolic syndrome why is
this paper so important role of
hyperuricemia in the development of
metabolic syndrome is not well
understood authors demonstrate deletion
of your a transporter route 9 in mines
embed enterocyte Eirik acid transport
kinetics resulted in full-blown
development of metabolic syndrome LLP
renal exam teen oxidase inhibitor
reversed the hypertension and
hypercholesterolemia increase in urea
does indeed resulted in metabolic
syndrome and eric braeden or partially
reverse the effect let us look at the
data in the knockout mice you know
blurting confirmed the deficiency of
total block 9 and gluten I name protein
in enterocytes compared to other tissues
isolated enterocytes from knockout mice
exhibited a 65-percent you rate uptake
defect versus white up and resides lcms
of stool extractor will significantly
decreased stool you rate concentration
in knockout mice together these results
suggested impaired intro security uptake
and flux into stool in knockout
author saw higher uric acid
concentration both in serum and urine in
knockout mice body composition analysis
by echo MRI revealed significantly
elevated fat mass and fat percentage in
knockout mice plus my analysis revealed
knockout mice had significantly elevated
total cholesterol triglycerides and free
fatty acids about forty percent
elevation in fasting plasma insulin in
knockout mice in contention of normal
fasting blood sugar significant baseline
hypertension in knockout mice was also
seen when compared to wild-type together
these results showed a total metabolic
syndrome in knockout mice now why type
and knockout mice were exposed to a
tweak of allopurinol in drinking water
approximately four weeks after weaning
plasma castle was significantly
decreased in knockout mice following
allopurinol treatment without
significant effect on you needed
concentrations in comparison with
untreated knockout mice el oppression or
treatment also lowered blood pressure
and total cholesterol without
significant effect on free fatty acids
and triglycerides suggesting partial L
Apeiron or mediated reversibility of
spontaneous metabolic syndrome in
knockout mice
others look into secondary complications
of hyperuricemia constant with
hyperuricemia patients hepatic free
fatty acids and triglycerides were
elevated in knockout cleavers versus
wild type livers in addition mrna for
sterol regulatory element-binding
protein a marker of cholesterol
metabolism was significantly elevated in
the livers of knockout mice increased
basal rate decreased diastolic left
ventricular internal diameter and
increased relative wall thickness a
common finding in patients with
hyperglycemia was also observed in
knockout mice allopurinol treatment
significantly lowered body weight and
hepatic triglyceride content but did not
significantly reverse the
knock out associated changes in heart
rate ventricular internal diameter or
relative wall thickness since not all
the symptoms are reversed by allopurinol
there might be other mechanism in play
in metabolic syndrome nevertheless
antracite gluten and transporter plays a
crucial role in metabolic syndrome as
shown in this study next let us look
into a paper published by reinhard cobb
in cell reports authors under I will the
function of breast cancer protein Baraka
one was this purpose so important bracha
one forms heterodimer with Brock
associated drink domain one protein and
promotes repair of double-stranded DNA
breaks loss of bra common function in
cells results in hypersensitivity to DNA
damage associated with the development
of cancer authors demonstrate bracha one
broad one dependent implicit relation of
histones at specific sites
identification of these sides may help
in the development of new tools for
cancer diagnosis let's look at the data
authors examined bracha one Brad one III
ligase activity on individual histone
proteins and reconstituted nucleosome
subsets in vitro easing
electrophoretically shift assay as shown
in this figure bracha 1 bar 1 eb cute
elating individual h2a h2b h3 and h4
proteins in vitro without any apparent
preference however when bracha one Brad
one was incubated with recombinant
nucleosomes are active chromatin only
h-2a was difficult elated indicating
specificity for h2 a to establish d3
ligase activity in vivo authors fused
ring domain of Draca one with M cherry
and transfected the cells and were able
to co-localize it with antibody for
ubiquitin and the co-localization was
not seen you
the presence of midian bracha one
quantity session of this experiment was
shown here similar co-localization was
also observed when h-2a antibody was
used in tent instead of fk2 to identify
the residue on h2 AUB could delay did
authors used mitad sta nucleosomes and
perform mobility shift assays with
bracha one as shown here bracha one
dependent hypocrite elation was markedly
reduced with the nucleosomes in which
both lysine 124 and 127 of h2 a were
mutated and this shift was further
reduced in 124 127 129 mutant in vega
cotransfection of h2m intent and in the
prostration studies with antibodies also
revealed similar results also for
transfection experiment with bracha one
bad one ring domains and h 2 m.e times
and even a precipitation experiments
also revealed the role of lysine 124 127
129 inhibited annihilation finally my
spectrophotometric analysis of chicken
erythrocyte chromatin shows
ubiquitylation of c-terminal peptide kak
residues 126 to 128 lies in 126 of
chicken h-2a is equivalent to lysine 127
in XZ nopers and human further
confirming the role of lysine 127 in a
mutilation so this study not only
confirms the role of praça one as e3
ligase but also identifies amino acids
in h2 a involved in acute elation and
this may help in generating antibodies
directed against s2 a 127 to 129
for use as a diagnostic tool to identify
by chemically active bracha one thank
you for watching science breakthroughs
from science mission